a hard hit single and a walk and the
mariners have a little something going
a couple of checks now the 3-1 pitch and
that one is lifted high in the air
short-centered
garcia's there tagging lewis he blocks
it now he's caught the tag
he got a little bit between ideas
and garcia made him pay to win the
inning
what a favor and a great job by adolesce
garcia i'm wondering if lewis assumed
this throw was going to third and so he
didn't have to hustle back they throw
behind him he slips and it's not even
close great execution by the rangers
so far this year five stars 3.33 era
good strikeout to walk ratio
this ball
sharply hit
and crawford
i don't know if that hit his glove his
leg i don't know exactly what that hit
karen's off to the right and calhoun is
on
calhoun's running and this one hit
sharply over third that one into the
left field corner
into third base calhoun will send
[Music]
get a look at the 14 fastball right down
the middle nick had fouled off the tough
pitches and then he squares up the
meatball and you see this ball go down
the line and with willie calhoun on the
move
that certainly gave him a great
opportunity to score as
with the way that this ball was played
by treval in that field
he could not cut it off
next pitch that one shot into right
field by garcia solak comes in to touch
the plate two-nothing rangers in the
first
[Applause]
chris woodward talk about unselfish team
at bats this is a cutter that sits
middle and you don't see a big swing
from odole's garcia he knows all that
room is available on the right side he
knows that he's got a runner in scoring
position and nick solak and so he
shortens his swing
crawford batting in the five spot the
highest he is batted in the order this
season
bulk of the time batting in the nine
hole
it's going to get down for base head
yeah i i like that scott service decided
to shake things up a little bit try to
get these guys going sometimes you can
jump start them by just changing guys
around in the lineup talking about it at
the beginning too all the high fastballs
that they've been seeing
and i was also talking about that which
i think is a good idea and that is for
them to start taking more of them and
not swinging it so many because they're
not doing much with them
you get it 3-2 he might have it's a good
ride left field
and it's gone
there you go
got a 2-2 ball game and you talked about
him fulton emmits giving up a lot of
home runs that's one tonight for the
mariners and good to see demo get on the
board here's third home run
comes right back 3-2 and this is center
cut was able to barrel it up
that's what you want to see that's how
you get yourself going get yourself into
some quality counts and
take advantage of it
tenth home run of the year that fulton
has given up just out of the reach of
doll in left field
isaiah has reached base safely now in a
career best 16 straight games
he's hitting almost 350 during that
stretch
bouncer up the middle and that one is
through you can make it 17 straight
games for isaiah
i don't consider myself a really good
eyeball hitter necessarily
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
another good team at bat look at that
change up 82 miles an hour look where
this thing finishes and there's
tremendous play coverage from willie
calhoun as he catches it just off the
end of the back but just enough
with the way that seeger was playing so
far in he had no chance
i mean it's that's the fourth pitch of
the inning i believe
you could get on the zoom and ask them
afterwards
get on that mariner zoom yeah i got a
pressing question
well he goes after this pitch so maybe
not a little flare out of the left
and wow
dawg stuck with it and on the slide
comes up with it
you're not sure who's going to be able
to get it till the very end there's
david dahl calling for it and making a
nice play in front of the shortstop that
was close
[Music]
now on the bottom of the third low
gallo and adolesce garcia
this ball hit well deep center field it
is down
and he never gets pull happy this is a
change-up decent movement but it's
elevated and he doesn't get
real big with the swing he tries to stay
in the middle of field and he absolutely
hammers this baseball no doubt
time france stiffy crawford dylan moore
four five and six here in the fourth
inning there's a ball hit on the butt
gets by the left fielder dawg
and a lead-off double for ty france
he has broken the curse
yeah darn right celebrate
third baseman culverson even with the
bag at third
taking the bun away
that's cranked down the line gone
two-round number jake pete crawford his
first of the season
ultimate just been an issue for him
376 feet exit velo of 105.
[Applause]
that hits him hurry on to gideon look
out
one no pitch
check swing fly ball a little pot long
run by doll
drops in fair there's a break
only fair but that side spin
[Applause]
kicks away from the outfielder he turns
it into a double
trying to get that lead back
and that will get it done
tremel coming around here's the throw it
is not in time throw down the second
haniker's in there safely
rbi single mitch haniger 5-4 mariners
here in the seventh
[Applause]
[Music]
great hitting breaking ball on the
outside corner maybe even off the edge
of the plate and he's able to beat their
defense they have to shift on
too much speed
with tremel running
hanniger also watching that he was going
to overthrow the cut off man so he just
keeps going and gets himself in the
scoring position
maniac almost the home plate waving him
around
on the screen there's a ground ball
third base that's a fair ball long throw
culverson in time
and they got him at first another
terrific defensive play by the rangers
and charlie was hugging the line
and he was in the right place at the
right time and makes an excellent play
look he's in foul territory by time he
comes up with this and it's a quick
exchange and a strong throw
[Applause]
here we go three and two
trying to
put a close
and he does
beautifully done what a bounce back by
the mariners after being no hit the
other day they win it by the final of
five to four in the in texas three game
winning streak